digamos que tenemos una mesa redonda
mesa redonda y en esa mesa tenemos tres
sillas una silla
otra silla
y otra silla que ya está le podemos
poner números a estas sillas esta va a
ser la silla número 1 está la número 2 y
está la silla número 3 y además tenemos
tres personas que se quieren sentar en
estas tres sillas porque tenemos a la
persona
y a la persona ve ya la persona se que
se quieren sentar en estas tres sillas y
lo que nosotros queremos contar es de
cuántas formas se pueden sentar estas
tres personas en estas tres sillas
porque ella ahorita vamos a ver
exactamente a qué me refiero a podría
llegar y sentarse en la silla 1 entonces
tenemos a en la silla 1 y b podría
sentarse en la silla 3 y se podría
sentarse en la silla 2 y entonces aquí
tenemos un escenario posible ok
este es un posible escenario la persona
a sentada en la silla número 1 se
sentada en la silla número
y la persona ve sentada en la silla
número 3 pero también podemos tener
muchos otros escenarios
por ejemplo la persona ve podría
sentarse en la silla uno ve en la silla
uno
la persona se podría seguir y sentándose
en la silla número 2
y entonces la persona tendría que
sentarse en la silla número 3
y este es otro de los posibles
escenarios gay este es un escenario y
este es otro escenario y la pregunta es
cuántos escenarios distintos tenemos así
es que te recomiendo que le pongas pausa
el vídeo y lo intentes por tu cuenta
bueno estoy pensando que ya lo
intentaste y ahora vamos a resolverlo
aquí pero de una forma muy sistemática o
para que no nos vaya a faltar ni un solo
escenario y la forma en la que lo voy a
hacer es que voy a poner por aquí tres
espacios vacíos que van a representar a
cada una de las sillas de esta mesa ok
este es el espacio que representa a la
silla número uno este representa a la
silla número 2 y este representa a la
silla número 3 y entonces vamos a
empezar por la silla número uno cuantos
escenarios tenemos para la silla número
uno pues en esta silla se puede sentar
con la persona o con la persona ve con
la persona se y cada una de esas
opciones es un escenario distinto
y ya que sepamos cuál es la persona que
se sienta en la silla número uno
entonces dejando fija a esa persona en
la silla número uno vamos a ver cuántos
escenarios hay para la silla número dos
y luego dejando fijarse la silla 1 y 2
vamos a ver cuántos escenarios hay para
la silla 3 entonces empezamos con la
silla 1 en la silla 1 podría llegar y
sentarse la persona
y si tenemos sentada a la persona en la
silla número 1 de todas formas no
sabemos quién está sentado en la silla
número 2 ni quién está sentado en la
silla 3 aunque ahora también podría
sentarse la persona ve en la silla 1 y
todavía no sabemos quién está en la
silla 2 ni en la silla 3 y finalmente
también podría llegar la persona se
sentarse en la silla 1 pero todavía no
sabemos quién está en la 2 ni quién está
en la 3 y ahora para cada una de estas
opciones podemos tratar de ver quiénes
están sentados en la silla número 2
entonces tenemos por aquí sillas
sillas 1 y 2
en este caso tenemos a la persona a
sentada en la silla 1 y entonces aquí
tenemos a y luego en la silla 2 se puede
sentar o la persona b o c así es que se
puede sentar la persona ve y bueno si
hacemos un poco de razonamiento
deductivo podríamos saber quién tiene
que estar sentado en la silla número 3
cierto pero bueno vamos a dejarlo así
por el momento así es que si tenemos
sentada a la persona
en la silla número 1 en la silla número
2 puede estar la persona ve o puede
estar la persona se y alguien más se
sienta en la silla 3
así es que estas son las dos posibles
opciones cuando estás sentada en la
silla número uno pero bueno qué pasa si
ahora ve es el que está sentado en la
silla número uno pues tenemos aquí ya ve
en la silla 1 y en la silla 2 se puede
sentar
jose así es que vamos a empezar con a y
en la silla 3 se sienta alguna otra
persona que otra vez puedes deducir
quién es el que se tiene que sentar en
la silla 3 o tenemos aquí a ver en la
silla 1 y se se puede sentar en la silla
2 y tenemos a alguien más en la silla 3
y estas dos son las dos opciones que
tenemos cuando b está sentado en la
silla número uno y finalmente si se está
sentado en la silla número uno en la
silla número dos se pueden sentar o a v
aunque tenemos ac en la silla número uno
entonces tenemos en la silla número dos
y alguna otra persona en la silla número
tres o tenemos hace en la silla 1 y
abdel en la silla 2 y alguien más en la
silla 3 cree estas son las dos opciones
que suceden cuando se se sienta en la
silla 1
ahora vamos a averiguar quiénes se
tienen que sentar en la silla tres en
cada uno de estos casos así es que
tenemos aquí las
sillas 1 2 y 3 que ahí vamos con este
caso tenemos a asentada en la silla 1 de
sentado en la silla 2 y entonces en la
silla número 3 se tiene que sentarse
porque se es la única persona que no
está sentada todavía bueno y qué pasa
por aquí pues la única opción para esta
silla es ve porque otra vez es la única
persona que no se ha sentado entonces
aquí hay únicamente una opción tenemos a
en la primera silla se en la segunda
silla y la única opción es que ve se
siente en la tercera silla por aquí lo
que tenemos es b a c ok porque se es la
única persona que todavía no se sienta y
por aquí a es la única persona que se
puede sentar aquí
y aquí que es la única persona que falta
y finalmente aquí la única opción es que
a se siente en la silla 3
así es que cuántos escenarios tenemos
aquí tenemos 1 2
5 y 6 y bueno tal vez en este punto tú
me digas es el tenemos tres sillas y
tres personas este es un ejemplo super
sencillo y podemos contarlos súper fácil
sin tener que contarlo de forma
sistemática pero qué pasaría si
tuviéramos 60 sillas por ejemplo bueno
ahí sí vamos a tener un montón de
escenarios pero por ejemplo en un caso
que parece más sencillo que tal que
tenemos 5 sillas y cinco personas aún
con ese número tan pequeño si usáramos
este mismo sistema ocuparíamos muchísimo
papel joven a muchísima pantalla y nos
tardaríamos mucho tiempo entonces qué se
hace en esos casos pues el chiste es
darse cuenta de qué es lo que pasa en el
fondo en este sistema porque tenemos por
aquí la silla uno la silla dos y la
silla tres y qué es lo que pasa aquí
si estamos sentando a las personas en
orden en estas sillas y todavía nos
sentamos a ni una sola persona entonces
cuántas opciones tenemos para sentar a
una persona en la silla número uno pues
lo tenemos aquí ok tenemos estas tres
opciones tres opciones porque tenemos
tres personas que podrían sentarse en la
silla 1 y luego ya que se sentó la
primera persona en la silla 1 para cada
uno de esos casos cuántas opciones
tenemos para que alguien se siente en la
silla 2 por aquí tenemos las opciones de
cuando la persona se sentó en la silla 1
y por aquí tenemos las opciones de este
caso y las opciones de este caso y si te
fijas en cada uno de estos casos tenemos
dos opciones dos opciones y eso sucede
porque ya que se sentó una persona en la
silla 1 entonces nos quedan únicamente
otras 2 personas que se podrían llegar a
sentar en la silla 2 aunque hay si a
esta sentada en la silla 1 entonces b o
c se pueden sentar en la silla 2 si ve
está sentado en la silla 1 entonces a
usted se pueden sentar en la silla 2 y
si se es el que está sentado en la silla
1 entonces a v se pueden sentar en la
silla 2 entonces para cada uno de estos
tres casos tenemos dos opciones así es
que por el momento tenemos tres por dos
seis opciones en total por el momento
y ahora lo que queremos ver es cada uno
de estos casos cuántas opciones tiene
pero como ya habíamos visto si ya
tenemos a dos personas sentadas tenemos
únicamente una opción la cual es que se
siente en la silla 3 la única persona
que no está sentada
aunque en este caso de aquí es la
persona
y aquí la única persona que falta es la
persona ve y aquí otra vez la única
opción es la persona a que cada uno de
estos casos tiene una sola opción y eso
es porque si ya se sentaron dos personas
en la mesa sólo nos queda una persona
que se puede sentar en la silla 3
así es que cuántos escenarios tenemos
tenemos 3 por 2 por 1 o sea 6
ahora si quisiéramos hacer lo mismo pero
ahora con cinco sillas y cinco personas
sentándose en esas sillas puede saber
tenemos por aquí 1 2 3
cuatro y cinco sillas y cinco personas
que se quieren sentar en estas sillas y
nos estamos preguntando de cuántas
formas se pueden sentar en estas sillas
así es que a ver para la primera silla
hay cinco personas que podrían sentarse
en ella entonces tenemos cinco casos ya
que tenemos a una persona sentada en la
primera silla y tenemos cinco posibles
situaciones para cada una de esas
situaciones cada uno de esos casos si
nos fijamos en la segunda silla ahora
sólo quedan cuatro personas que podrían
sentarse en la segunda silla entonces
para cada uno de estos casos tenemos
cuatro opciones y ya que tenemos a dos
personas sentadas entonces sólo nos
quedan tres personas sin sentarse así es
que tenemos tres opciones y luego solo
quedan dos personas sin sentarse
entonces tenemos dos opciones
ya que se sentaron cuatro personas solo
nos queda una persona o sea que hay
únicamente una opción así es que la
cantidad de escenarios la cantidad de
formas de sentar a cinco personas en
cinco sillas es 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 por
1 o sea 20 por 6 y 20 por 6 es 120 como
puedes observar el número de escenarios
posibles aumenta rapidísimo pero bueno
este tipo de cosas 3 por 2 por 1 y 5 por
4 por 3 por 2 por 1 como que se ven como
una operación matemática súper padre no
y de hecho si es una operación
matemática definida y muy famosa por
cierto
ok eso de empezar con un número y luego
multiplicarlo por ese número menos 1 por
ese número menos 2 y así seguirse es la
función que se llama factorial ok y se
escribe 5 con un símbolo de exclamación
y por aquí lo que tenemos es 3 factorial
y si por ejemplo nos encontráramos por
ahí con un 6 factorial esto lo que
significa es empezamos con 6
por 5 por 4 por 3 por 2 y por 1 en fin
espero que te haya parecido interesante